announcement the steelers made this
morning and it never really is all that
clear when mike tomlin and the steelers
are negotiating a new contract
you don't hear much about it but you do
hear about it directly from the team
when there's a new deal tomlin
three-year extension
through 2024 if he coaches out
that extension four more seasons it will
mean that the steelers
have gone 56 seasons with a total
of three head coaches unbelievable
and tomlin still late 40s
he could go another 15 20 years as coach
of the steelers he's already been on the
job since 2007.
so again who is one of the more
accomplished coaches in the nfl he's got
that super bowl win from early in his
tenure he will
continue to be the man in pittsburgh
they might be the greatest organization
in the nfl
if not all of sports mike just the way
they handle the coaching position
they hire somebody they think is going
to be really good they put
faith in them and they leave them there
for however long they want to stay there
and you look at the two previous coaches
before mike tomlin they're in the hall
of fame right they were great coaches
and mike tomlin has done the same the
fact that the guy's never
had a losing record is just amazing to
me for as long as he's been there 14
years now
never had a losing record it's just
unbelievable but only steelers fans
would be upset about this and i saw some
comments on twitter oh lord we don't
want him to
stay that long we need a new head coach
are you kidding me
you win every single year you're a
contender
every single year be grateful that
mike tomlin is your coach if this guy
left tomorrow he would have 10 job
offers in the nfl
there's a pocket of steelers fans though
and it's not just a pocket it's a seam
it's a significant percentage when
things are going
poorly they immediately start clamoring
for a new coach and i don't get it i
know there was a time when
some of the limited partners in steelers
ownership
were trying to get art rooney the second
who runs the team
to change coaches there was a perception
tomlin didn't have control of the team
and
rooney to his credit just tells them
okay
thank you point take and you have no
power here please leave
but one of the things i have heard from
other coaches about tomlin and
look pro football coaches are wired to
think
they're the best at what they do there
is an abundance
of confidence bordering on delusion they
aren't all that willing to start
throwing bouquets
at their competitors i've heard from
other head coaches
what a good coach mike tomlin is because
one thing he does
he finds a way to get the absolute most
out of every player that he has and if
it happens to be a player who would be a
problem
he keeps him from being a problem for
the most part now
with antonio brown it eventually bubbled
over but there have been other guys who
it isn't until they go somewhere else
that they become a problem
and mike tomlin is one of the main
reasons why
those players respond to him listen to
him
follow him and win for him and whatever
their talent would suggest they would
have been since 2007
they're better wins and loss is better
than what their talent
otherwise would have indicated if
someone else had been coaching the team
no question mike and i have
no no no no
thoughts that mike tomlin won't outlast
chuck noll i think he's going to be
there longer than chuck norris i don't
think there's any doubt about that
no doubt whatsoever about that molly
question is does he win as many
championships
as chuck knowl did and that of course is
the big question and where steelers fans
come in and say all right he won a super
bowl second year
we've been back once since we're three
and six since the last super bowl
appearance
we want more i get that they're used to
winning all those super bowls in the
1970s the four that chuck noll was able
to win
and then obviously you had bill cower
come in and stay a short period of time
and win another one
they want more of those super bowls i
get it but it's also a different era
than than the 1970s it's harder to do
it's harder to get back
and yet every single year he has them in
position
people seem to forget last year that
this is a team to start at 11-0 and i
get it they probably weren't an 11-0
team
but the fact is they started 11-0 last
season we were still talking about them
potentially going to the super bowl
at 11-0 and they didn't do it we know
that it was disappointing finish in the
postseason
but they're always there mike and i will
be interested to see if mike talmud can
do what chuck noll did in winning as
many championships i do think they'll
win another one
will it get to four i i doubt that it's
just harder to do now but i do think
he'll win another
at least one more in his time in
pittsburgh
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports